حصيله قتلى بالعشرات هي الحرب في اوكرانيا
وان مضت يومياتها احيانا متشابهه او
تزاحمت فوقها ملابسات السياسه عصر الخميس
اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني والاداره العسكريه
في اقليم خاركيف مقتل العشرات في قصف روسي
استهدف مقها ومتجر في قريه بمنطقه كوبيان
في المقابل اعلن جهاز الامن الاوكراني
استهداف شبكه الكهرباء باقليم كورسك
الروسي بمسيرات ما قطع التيار عن منشات
عسكريه روسيه مهمه في هجوم قال انه ليس
الاول في المنطقه واعلنت مصادر اوكرانيه
ايضا تعرض مطار كورسك لهجوم بطائره دون
طيار اما حاكم مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه رومان
ستارو فويت فتحدث من جانبه عن اصابه امراه
بشظايا وتضرر منشات وممتلكات اثر تعرض
مدينه ريلك لقصف اوكراني بالذخائر
عنقوديه خارج الحدود الاكرانيه تتجاوب
كعادتها اصداء الحرب يعلن اقليم ابخازيا
الانفصالي عن جورجيا اعتزام روسيا اقامه
قاعده بحريه دائمه على البحر الاسود اعلن
ذلك زعيم ابخازيا يوم الخميس بعد نحو
اسبوعين من هجمات اوكرانيه تعرضت لها
قياده اسطول البحر الاسود في شبه جزيره
القرم التي باتت هدفا معتادا لاوكرانيا
منذ ذلك الهجوم الذي تضاربت انباء حصيله
قتلاه بدا ان روسيا تب حث عن منفذ اخر على
البحر الاسود وقالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه هذا الاسبوع ان انشطه اسطول
البحر الاسود تنقل بشكل متزايد الى قاعده
بحريه روسيه في الشرق مرجحه انها في
نوفوروسيسك
الروسيه الحرب دائره بين طرفين يتبادلان
الايلام ويخشى الاوكرانيين تحديدا من
تسارع الايام وانقطاع امل الحلفاء من جني
ثمار الهجوم المضاد على مشار في الخريف
وتقلباته مخاوف استبقاء الدعم الغربي تضغط
على المسؤولين في كيف فيطير الرئيس
الاوكراني الى غرناطه منخرطا في قمه
الاتحاد الاوروبي والشركاء حيث يخيم الحذر
من انقطاع دعم الشريك الامريكي اثر سجالات
داخليه ويؤكد مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل ان الاتحاد
يعمل على تعزيز مساعداته لاوكرانيا لكن
اوروبا بالتاكيد
قوله لا يمكن ان تملا فراغ الولايات
المتحده في هذا
الشان